[Music]
luca is a story of friendships
that are authentic and only found around
a
certain age we underdogs have to look
out for each other right
underdogs i love this moment in a
young person's life having someone push
you out of your comfort zone to discover
yourself there's a certain innocence to
this
it's really kind of beautiful come on
i had the luck of meeting my best friend
alberto when i was 11.
he had a ton of passion and was
consciously testing his own fears
who's holding the ramp the turtle i
wonder if i would have had the courage
to
go and chase my career in animation had
i not met my best friend
i really loved watching the friendship
between luca julia and alberto
i'm hoping that it will bring back a lot
of memories for people of summers when
they were kids
my birthday is in the summer so a lot of
really really good childhood memories of
summertime and it was always a pool
party
let's go swim i guess that's how humans
swim
that's embarrassing some kids go away to
camp and you're like
where my dogs at but then the key ones
that are in town
they like to party
these are the friendships that teaches
lessons build your self-esteem
and you have like the sense of belonging
i got friends that believe in me who
push me like i would tell them an idea
that i have and they'd be like
make it do it this movie is the perfect
example of that
they use friendships that help us find
ourselves that is really at the heart of
the story of luka
[Music]
you